Konnor in southeastern Ohio you're on
the bench perestroika for Conor I just
have a question I live right on the
border of Ohio in West Virginia and of
course West Virginia has the mass
mandate right now and there's a lot of
people going to the stores and arguing
about constitutional freedom of wearing
masks and I've obviously never heard of
anything about masks in the Constitution
and I just wanted to know what would you
argue for or against so the idea that
you have a constitutional freedom not to
wear a mask in the middle of a public
health crisis is pretty weak states have
a lot of public health power they do
under the state constitutions they have
the ability to do all sorts of stuff to
restrict your freedoms in the case of
external threat it is why in times of
war the federal government has the power
to basically you know take over
businesses and do all sorts of stuff
that we would never normally give the
go-ahead to local health authorities do
indeed have the constitutional authority
to say things like you need to wear a
mask or you'll get fined in the same way
that they have the authority to have a
seatbelt rule right you gotta wear a
seatbelt or you'll be fine now you may
disagree with both you may think on a
libertarian level you gotta protect
yourself we can rely on social
institutions to implement that on a
legal level it would be very difficult
to challenge in court the idea that a
local authority can't tell you to wear a
mask in public unless it were clearly
unreasonable right if the rule were you
need to wear a mask a hundred feet away
from others in a public area then and
you got fine for that it'd be difficult
to uphold that in a court of law but
barring that the idea that you go to a
target and now you have to wear a mask
that that is is some sort of violation
of the government's role not not a lot
of support for that and that that really
is you say it's not really even an
argument as to whether the masks are a
good idea or a bad idea and I think the
evidence so far has been relatively
mixed on masks I mean I've seen some
studies that suggest up until 2017 by
the way this was the position of the CDC
is that masks were not particularly
effective in terms of transmission of
things like flu I and then you've seen
some other studies that have said that
masks have helped slow the spread in a
lot of areas because they at least
reduce the risk of droplets escaping
escaping the mask on the way out even
though they don't stop tiny tiny
particles from getting into the mask
yeah I think that you know bottom line
in the end not my feeling is that all we
can really do is just protect people who
are the most vulnerable by telling
to stay home in Santa public areas and
other than that I'm really not sure that
you can do much more than that unless
you were talking about when one things
people are trying to do and this is
getting into the broader kovat topic
Connor
well one of the things that that people
are trying to do is compare countries
where they had very very low caseload at
the very beginning to countries that had
very high caseload almost nearly from
the start at the United States by the
time we even identified this thing it
was it wasn't like it started with one
case it was like it was seeded
everywhere right it was seated in New
York it was seated in California it was
seated in Texas who's seated nearly
everywhere and that was just not the
case in places like South Korea or Hong
Kong or Taiwan where there a couple of
cases they picked it up incredibly fast
because they're used to this sort of
thing because of SARS and then they were
able to lock things down pretty quickly
until they crushed the curve the United
States didn't have the ability to do
that it was already too prevalent and so
you end up with the thing you know with
communities spread it's hard to see how
in a United States that has literally
millions of active cases at this point
you don't stop that community spread is
somehow prevented by mask-wearing at
best you might be able to slow
transmission to the point where it
doesn't overwhelm the hospital system
and I guess that's the idea yeah I'm a
server so I met master mandatory for us
at this point
yeah and again I that makes some sense
and by the way I think that it's
actually a good business practice I like
the fact that the servers are wearing
masks it makes me more comfortable
because I would not be super comfortable
somebody breathing on the food just
about to hand it to me so that makes
some sense to me just as a voluntary
business practice exactly and we even I
work at Roadhouse and we've actually
made patios for cook with it outside
they're uncomfortable sitting inside
that's great pretty good that's great I
mean again I think the businesses are
adapting to this sort of thing and I
think that's a very good thing and I
think that as businesses adapt you know
we should I've said all along I think
that you can trust the American people
not to be complete idiots um yeah some
some Americans will try to prove me
wrong but I think that most Americans
are not being completed it's about this
thing and you can see this in the
behavior the truth is that the stay at
home orders those are actually late on
the game if you look at the the records
of how people traveled and how people
move people that stopped traveling and
moving pretty quickly as soon as they
found out about this thing like I know
that my family we basically started
locking down like I believe that it was
March 11th the actual formal lockdown
order and Los Angeles didn't come until
the following week so that you
I think most Americans sort of did the
same thing Connor I really appreciate
the call Frankie in Detroit Michigan
you're in the bend you're on the bench
brush I'll go farm Frankie I had a quick
question that kind of stew
what's up we were talking about your
book first what can the average American
do to defend against the u.s. against
this integrationist and kind of
following up on that really quickly you
tweeted recently that a button wins
he'll see it as an endorsement by the
American people of an ambitious
revisionist agenda in which case
Americans will just snap back and vote
him out so is it the case that the
Americans do need to push back against a
signature graciousness or Americans will
just naturally snap back against a
revisionist agenda so I think that it's
that there will be both so there will be
a natural snapback because this is so
radical but the problem is that every
time the radicals pull if they're trying
to pull you all the way to a 10 and they
only accomplish pulling America over to
a 1 toward their side that's a win for
them right just a just standing in place
William F Buckley once famously stated
that conservatism was the job of
standing athwart history yelling stop
right but if the trains coming down the
track even if you're Superman and you
stop the train you'll skip back a couple
of feet and that skid back a couple of
feet is worth a lot for the left because
if they keep doing it over and over and
over if they keep pile-driving americans
over to the left they don't have to do
it all at once they can do it
incrementally and they know this right
they push for everything at once just so
they can get an incremental sort of
victory it's like your kids when your
kids fuss and they scream and they cry
and they scream they're looking for you
to compromise just a little bit right
because no fuss though they'll bring the
fussing up to attend just to get one out
of you and then that's sort of what the
left does what that means is that the
snapback needs not just to be you know
we're going to not give you virtually
anything that you want
it's got to be we need to remake a lot
of the major institutions in American
society including our education system
which is busily teaching kids that
America is a terrible place we need to
rethink how we do colleges in this
country we need to rethink how we hire
people out of college in this country I
have suggested for a long time there
needs to be some sort of institution
that basically sorts people by
intellectual ability right that's what
colleges effectively do but does not
require you to go through four years of
indoctrination to get a job or you
should be able to take the SAT and then
you should be able to get an imprint a
ship with a business and you don't have
to go through all the indoctrinating
nonsense that you get at colleges and
universities I saw a poll today by the
way of Harvard of Harvard faculty it
showed 80% considered themselves a
liberal 19% considered themselves
moderate 1% considered themselves
conservative what do you think kids are
gonna think coming out of college none
of this is a shock so what can we do to
fight this integration is and we can
fight in the culture to retake
instruments of culture and provide
competing avenues in the culture not
just win elections or wait for the snap
back Frankie appreciate the call all
righty
Tamara in Ohio you're on the bench Bo
she'll go far tomorrow I lost my job and
I had been fought applying for
unemployment I got a stimulus check but
I was just wondering like where exactly
is this money from coming from I got
more than way more than I expected and I
know that there are a lot of people who
are working right now making less than
that so my question basically was just
how is this gonna how is this gonna
affect the economy and our people gonna
have to pay this money back when tax
season comes around next year so the
answer is probably people will have to
pay you some money back when the taxes
come around next year especially if Joe
Biden is elected gone from it you know
this is basically being borrowed from
the future because the fact is that no
matter how high you raise taxes next
year there just isn't the money to pay
back the the several trillion dollars
that we just spent over the course of
the last three months and probably will
be extended I think there will probably
be another round of this considering the
high levels of unemployment and the
continued prevalence of kovat so we're
just racking up the debt at this point
now the fact is that because we are
still the world's strongest horse in
terms of the economy we should be able
to continue borrowing but there will be
consequences down the line like right
now people are buying American bonds
because it's not like there's tons of
other places to buy but down the line if
the American economy starts to shrink in
real measures not just because of kovat
down the line if we raise taxes and the
economy starts to fall apart then you'll
start to see America have to inflate the
dollar or raise taxes to exorbitant
level so do I think it'll happen next
year I think there will be some tax
increases next year I think the biggest
tax increases are gonna come over the
next five years I think you're gonna see
it on the state and local level first I
think you'll see it on the federal level
as well but it'll be mostly at the top
marginal tax bracket I think in
California they're just gonna go for
broke I think in California over the
next five years considering all the debt
they've been in current I think you're
going
see the top 10 the top the rates in
California the income tax rates in
California give an example because I
know the income tax rates in California
because I literally weep over them each
and every year the income rate in in
California the top tax rate in in
California is twelve point three percent
which is the highest state income tax
rate in America I believe within five
years that number will be closer to 20
the basic sales tax rate in California
at 7.25 percent which is also the
highest I think that that will look more
like 10% and I think that you're gonna
see this happen all over America I think
that you're right I mean listen at a
certain point you can't pay all these
bills you can't and it's particularly
true at the state level at the federal
level you can take out debt at the state
level you really have no capacity to run
a deficit forever you can't declare
bankruptcy obviously and you can't print
your dollars out of it my question I
appreciate it tomorrow Sam in Santa Rosa
California around the Ben Shapiro show
go for it Sam hey watch the Sunday
special that you release with the
analogical darkweb best of Oz watch Ben
I was wondering q competing principle
seems like they could come up if you are
so you're the principle that you're
driven by data but you also have morals
in general like free markets they're
good you should have the right to do
what you want with your business so
let's say that evidence started piling
up which I don't think it is but let's
say that it did start piling up that you
know minimum wage increases have all the
benefits that its proponents say or
increasing regulation you know increases
prosperity blah blah blah which
principle would you stick with the
evidence that helped the economy or that
good for free market the answer is that
it's good for free markets the reason
being that my pure vision of government
is that you have rights that pre-exists
government those rights include your
ability to dispense with your own labor
and to hire people through voluntary
contract and so the idea that you're
going to Trump that with economic
efficiency that's right there's no
limiting principle there right this
actually came up in a Supreme Court case
there's a very famous Supreme Court case
called kilo in which the Supreme Court
basically declared that a state could
use eminent domain in order to
confiscate a property from one private
owner and hand it to another private
owner to create more tax revenue
so they could come to your house
normally the way that it works is the
government wants to build the road right
they come to your house they confiscate
your house they pay you for your house
and then they pave your house because
they're building a government road
that's happen until Maine okay in this
case the government wanted to seize
somebody's house and build and and and
literally take the territory and hand it
to like Marriott to build a hotel to
another private property literally take
your property and hand it to me because
I'm building a Marriott whereas you have
a house and the tax revenue back to the
state is higher and the Supreme Court
said oh yeah this is totally fine it's
for public use okay now that's not
public use in my opinion that's a
violation of the rights of the homeowner
and sure you'd be creating more tax
revenue and more economic activity but
you don't have the right to abuse
eminent domain in order to confiscate
property from one person and give it to
another it's a violation of rights I
feel the same way about minimum wage
minimum wage you know it just so happens
the minimum wage actually kills
employment but if minimum wage do not
kill employment I still do not believe
the government has the right to dictate
to you how to pay people or what people
are allowed to take or whom to hire or
whom to fire I think that that's all
those are all aspects of freedom and
that goes back to fundamental vision of
of government which again is about the
chief threats to people and human nature
and to me the greatest threat is people
who believe they are the most brilliant
thinkers and the most imaginative
policymakers having complete control of
your life to do what's best for you and
that scares the living hell out of me as
I think it should every sane and
rational human being Sam appreciate the
call